you're co-starring in Tomb Raider and
this is a big movie and you were
co-starring with Alicia of accont
is it vikander Elisheva case she's
Alicia vikander and she is she's all
she's been on the show and she's such a
great person I think she might be the
most attractive woman on the planet
she's just absolutely stunning stunning
I agree with you yeah and I'm curious I
mean who got in better shape for this
she has to be the Tomb Raider yo yeah he
has to get in serious shape and I heard
she did get in serious yeah she put
she put on 12 pounds of muscle you know
and and I I put on three yeah but that
was it and I just remember looking at
her back for the first time when we were
like in there and she was in her in her
tank top and we were walking out and I
was kind of behind to her walking into
this tomb or whatever and looking at her
back thinking that I will never have a
back like that yeah
bicep like that I don't have a six-pack
like that yeah and yeah yes she's she's
pretty remarkable I first time I ever
went to a gym the guy said to me like
we're gonna build up the muscles in your
back and I didn't know there were
muscles back there sore they exploded
into flame in I had no I was like what
are you talking about it was like no
there's stuff here and I'm like does not
stop a tear there's nothing there
there's just you know croutons you know
I used to be a personal trainer well did
the one thing that she did have you're a
personal trainer I was a personal
trainer you were a clogger and you and
you traveled the country on $100 yes all
kinds of stuff all kinds of stuff about
me yeah but but she she would eat this
this diet man she had a Magnus this
trainer he's an amazing guy and they
they would feed her this the salmon and
we kind of showed up Dominic West who's
also in the movie and I we got to set
and I think they just kind of felt bad
for us because they you know no one was
cooking us food so that they said no
actually it's your chef too but not
really we were just eating her leftover
fish like you guys whatever she didn't
eat we would you were like dogs Kenner
was having this great meal and then if
there was a little bit of salmon left
they would put it in a bowl
yeah yeah and put on some muscle please
yeah well we have a clip here from tomb
raider I don't know if this e needs any
setup I think this is you guys fighting
well yeah okay yeah yeah it was uh we're
taught yes she she she I think I can say
this she wins but I mean she yeah I
think the honor of International Women's
Day we should point out that although if
that's not shown in this clip yeah she
she cleans your clock she clean yes she
claims yes she kicks some ass she kicks
my bad that's what she does
yeah yes she gives it to me what did you
become a Mormon all the south community
all right let's take a look at this clip
from Tomb Raider
[Music]
you really want to do this little girl
let's just go home
cheers yo seriously cut yes cut
yeah it's just so good too
[Applause]
you